[Music]
this is singer-songwriter Tom Spate
doing what he loves making music his is
an industry that is notoriously
competitive and fickle but Tom says it
has become more democratic because of
how fans access artists
I've been doing music for 10 years and
releasing music for the last seven and
that's purely down to streaming you know
before streaming was you know on the
cards I was selling CDs for a rucksack
and now I'm you know playing shows in
Brazil and that's purely down to
streaming more people are listening to
music through online platforms like
Spotify and apple music than ever before
new figures show that amounted to more
than 150 billion audio streams last year
more than double what it was five years
ago and for the first time all of last
year's top 10 singles that's streamed or
sold were songs by or featuring UK
artists tracks by Harry Styles and Ed
Sheeran were the most popular American
artists wanting to collaborate with
British artists more and around the
world as well we're seeing our music
being used on Tick Tock worldwide and
artists wanting to to You Know Remix and
be a part of British music and I think
it's fabulous and there's also an
appetite for listening to music the way
we used to with vinyl making a big
comeback but it's new material and
younger fans streaming and social media
may have revolutionized the music
industry but it seems there is still a
market for Nostalgia Becky Cottrell Sky
News
oh he knew that numbers could be so fun
zookeepers at London Zoo were given the
job of counting up all of the animals as
its annual stock take we're carrying for
more than 300 species they tallied up
every mammal bird reptile fish and
invertebrate 2022 saw the arrival of
many new animals to the zoo from Sumatra
and tiger cubs to Humboldt penguin
chicks and Tiny pygmy goats well once
all of the animals are counted the
information is then shared with other
zoos around the world where it's used to
help manage worldwide conservation